the biggest movies of last year had some
pretty amazing moments and we've
devoured hours of blockbuster excellence
in order to experience the best here are
some of the most epic movie moments from
2018 that are either pores worthy in
order to take it all in or deserve a
rewind to watch again the childish
little sister Cherie is an engineering
genius so when she shows off all the
technical gadgets she's invented to help
her big brother be the Black Panther
there are definitely a bunch of moments
when you might want to pause and examine
each invention a little more closely
fully automated like the old American
movie barber used to watch but the most
rewind worthy moment comes towards the
end of the scene when T'Challa is
checking out his new black panther suits
at first sure Ian plows him to give the
suit a kick and that goes flying but a
sure he explains the suitors absorbed
the kinetic energy left by two challahs
kick and a suit glows purple whether
it's building strength then Sheree asked
him to attack again Sheree and the
audience erupted in laughter at the
sight of the great black panther leveled
by a suit on a mannequin it's a moment
that's definitely worth a rewatch
watching Avengers infinity war it's hard
to say if anyone really believe that
Thanos was going to succeed in his plot
to wipe out half the population of the
universe but then he got all six
Infinity stones into that gauntlet and
well everyone knows what happened next
Oh after the snap of the dusting begins
first to go is Bucky followed by black
panther groot Scarlet Witch and Falcon
Alton Space mantis Drax star-lord and
Doctor Strange dissolve into space dust
but the most crushing dusting has got to
be that of spider-man who's pleading
with Tony Stark is absolutely tragic I
don't know what it go spirit please
how many people pour some parkas
heartbreaking final moments we can only
guess hopefully we'll find out soon
enough of our favorite Avengers are
saved when Avengers end game hits
theaters there are a few pretty awesome
palsworthy moments in Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom 2018 sequels of 2015's
follow up to the original Jurassic Park
franchise this new movie introduced
another scary dinosaur hybrid the
interrupter which when it's finally
revealed deserves a good pause just so
we can get a good look at there but
Jurassic world fallen kingdom's most
pores worthy moment comes around the
middle of the film when claire owen and
the gang tried to evacuate the remaining
dinos before our volcano eruption kills
them
but the bigger dinosaurs move more
slowly and one unlucky Brachiosaurus
doesn't make it off the island in the
saddest moment of the movie the poor guy
is engulfed in smoke and we hear a final
heartbreaking bellow from the Beast
before he collapses into the cloud of
ash
[Music]
[Music]
it deserves a pause just so we can get
in a moment of mourning before moving on
to more action for technically being
part of the x-men franchise there are
surprisingly few x-men characters in the
first step or movie a fact which
Deadpool isn't shy about pointing out
it's a big house
it's funny that I only ever see two of
you it's almost like the studio couldn't
afford another x-man
but Deadpool too takes it a bit further
and adds a fun cameo when Colossus
brings a severely injured Wade back to
the x-mansion Wade remarks again at the
lack of x-men characters willing to make
an appearance and his knockoff x-men
movie which is exactly when they appear
he can't just dust off one of the famous
x-men how about that putz with the giant
pigeon wings what do those do anyway huh
carrying three feet off the ground to
snatch up the nearest muffin crumb the
fun gag is worth of pours just so we can
check out who's in the room Xavier Beast
Quicksilver Cyclops storm and Mike
crawler
the latest installment to the mission
impossible franchise features some of
the most intense action sequences in
movie history the biggest and most
talked about has got to be the halo jump
star Tom Cruise takes from a plane
flying 25,000 feet in the air
[Music]
the detail behind what it took to
capture the jump on film absolutely
insane
Cruz is the first actor to perform such
a stunt which is saying a lot about his
willingness to capture authenticity he
and the crew took over 100 jumps to get
the scene just right while every other
jump required at least 20 minutes of
oxygen crab and since the shots in the
movie happens as sunsets they only had
one chance per day to actually shoot the
scene
it's pause worthy just because of how
stunning the whole thing is and because
when she watch it you simply have to
know how it was done like the first
movie marvels ant-man and the wasp is
filled of light-hearted and hilarious
moments that counter the more dire and
serious aspects of the Marvel Universe
when Lewis gets captured by sunny birch
he's given a truth serum and forced to
divulge all he knows about Scott Lang
but this is Lewis Scott's blunt yet
hilarious best friend so when he's given
a truth serum you can bet he's going to
tell you everything
Lewis's story goes all the way back to
when he and Scott met in person complete
with an enormous curly wig then through
his relationships of hope and this guy
he's like you don't walk girl my heart's
all broken and I'll probably never find
love again but damn if I want to kiss
him the whole scene is definitely the
funniest sequence in the film one that
you'll probably want to re-watch
throughout the Star Wars prequels solo a
Star Wars story Emilia Clarke's Keira
and Paul Bettany strident buzz make
references to a higher criminal
organization known as crimson dawn
drawing the climax of the film Kiera
slays Dryden and abandons her love of
her life han Solo it's at that point
that she pledges allegiance to crimson
dawn via hologram and a familiar face
pops up in the holographic communication
device Darth Maul it was a moment that
left audience members collectively
gasping but also asking how casual Star
Wars movie viewers were recalled that
Darth Maul met his end at the hands of
obi-wan Kenobi drawing The Phantom
Menace but fans of the animated series
Clone Wars and rebels know that Maul
survived has fall and became a crime
boss who runs the organization known as
the shadow collective which in turn runs
crimson dawn meanwhile Solo takes place
a couple of decades after the Phantom
Menace moles reveal is definitely a
plausible moment if only for fans to try
and figure out if they're really seeing
who they think they're seeing and work
out the timeline of how the former Sith
Lord has turned crime boss ended up
there
some Hardys Fannin was one of the
weirdest movie experiences of last year
and very much one of the most bizarre
Marvel inspired movies that has ever
existed fans can't seem to decide if it
was amazing or awful intentionally campy
or just bad all around but it does
feature one of the most talked about
moments of the cinematic year the Eddie
Brock and venom makeout session was it
really between Eddie and venom was it
between Eddie and his ex-girlfriend and
all we know is when venom is inhabiting
Anne's body venom leans in for a deep
and intense full tongue kiss considering
that venom is in charge whenever it's
inhabiting someone it certainly seems
like it was venom who made the call to
go in deep pucker up
through its use of sound a quiet place
became one of the most innovative horror
films and years John Krasinski's
directorial debut told the story of a
family struggling to survive after a
race of alien invaders took over the
planet
the creatures use sound to find their
prey so being absolutely quiet is
essential to survival the lack of sound
in much of the film makes the
suspenseful moments even more intense
and allows the tension to build but the
most pause worthy moment comes right at
the end when the mother Evelyn and her
deaf daughter Regan face off against the
creatures one final time Regan realizes
a cochlear implants can be altered to
emit a high-pitched sound that wounds
the creatures upon dimming so the one
hunting them opens up its face to reveal
the inner workings of the alien beast
[Music]
until that point the creatures that
stayed mostly in the shadows but this
close look provides the best detail of
the entire movie it's a shot you
definitely want to pause just to get a
good look before Everland blows its head
off if you love Queen then you probably
loved Bohemian Rhapsody any of the
musical moments in this foam armor wind
were they particularly the recording
session of Bohemian Rhapsody itself but
the most epic scene in the entire movie
is definitely the closing sequence which
revolves around the band's decision to
perform at Live Aid a giant charity
concert that took place simultaneously
in London and Philadelphia in 1985 the
movie pretty much recreates Queens
entire performance and rami malek has
said he considers a concert the most
important scene in the film telling
cinema blend it is a combination of what
the trials and tribulations were that
got them there in the first place and
they still have something monumental to
overcome so I think if you look at this
film a lot of it is about overcoming
adversity and challenging every aspect
of yourself and your friends the 2018
Halloween is technically a direct sequel
to the 1978 original even though there
have been six other movies between them
this reckoning of the series brings back
Jamie Lee Curtis as Laurie Strode and
adds a daughter named Karen and the
granddaughter names Alison a story
follows a return of Michael Myers as he
escapes from a prison-transport and
heads out on a killing spree on the hunt
for Laurie Jamie Lee Curtis plays Laurie
now in her 60s with a world where eNOS
and severe PTSD and she certainly has
some moments of badassery in the movie
but the moment many fans talked about
most has more to do with the usually
sweet Judy Greer though Laurie's
daughter was taken from her at an early
age
Karen comes through for her in a clutch
moment
gotcha the level of ridiculousness in
the mag reaches pretty epic proportions
but despite being pretty goofy the movie
is still a whole lot of fun Jason
Statham stars as a guy trying to capture
and kill a really big shark a Megalodon
to be precise and that's about the
entire premise but what it lacks in
story it makes up for by just going all
the way the most epic scene in the
entire movie comes about midway through
when the gang of shark hunters has
captured the Meg and strung a
prehistoric creature up on their boats
or at least they think they've captured
the Meg
the meg took a crazy premise our made it
even crazier by making its massive
villain even bigger there's nothing more
exciting than a good movie gunfight but
the one-sided showdown from hold the
dark isn't your typical Hollywood
shootouts this incredibly tense scene
finds a group of ill-equipped cops
facing a very angry man with a very big
machine gun his name is cheon and when
the police roll into his icy little
village looking to arrest him and his
friend for murder
he opens up his second-story window and
unleashes hell with an m60 the entire
scene is nothing but ice blood
adrenaline and fear bodies drop left and
right and the soundtrack is filled of
screaming man as cheon shoots them over
and over again it's like watching a clip
from Saving Private Ryan and by the time
the police put Cheon down we need to hit
the pause button so we can slow down our
heart rate and try to get our breath
back check out one of our newest videos
right here Plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Applause]
[Music]